Candyman the urban legend is if you say  its name five times by looking in the  mirror he appears in the reflection and  it kills you who would do that Candyman  Candyman Candyman well we're still alive  let's go Trina you broke the door  I feel really connected to this  neighborhood cabrini-green it was the  projects that just moved in around the  corner they all candy tracks I'm an  artist you look up the Candyman he's the  monster it's part of this neighborhood  why are you drawn to this I'm hoping to  spread the story all about Candyman the  mirror invites you to summon him you  should say his name I dare you  Candyman Candyman Candyman Candyman  don't say - candy me  [Music]  I think it made a mistake  I'll quarterback Candyman isn't real  something's happening to me  [Music]  he had a purpose for you to be another  one is terrible stories  Larvik do  [Music]  [Music]